Hey youtubers it's Charlie and Marvel just
revealed that they're making Thor a female
character this fall. So I'm going to breakdown
specifically what's changing, which female
they're giving the hammer to and how it's
going to affect the future of the movie universe
way way down the road.
Hello any new people, I do weekly Marvel videos
for the movies and tv shows. Be sure to subscribe
to get everything. I've got a bunch of comic
con stuff planned for next week too.
Right of the bat let's look at what Marvel
actually said. This is just happening in the
comics. In the wake of Original Sin, Thor
will no longer be deemed worthy of wielding
Mjolnir by Odin's inscription. So instead
of just sitting in a closet, the Hammer will
pass to a new person. That person will be
a female.
What did Thor do that it lost him the Hammer?
During Original Sin, the Thor storyline revolves
around Angela and explaining why she's the
sister of Loki and Thor and why we just met
her this past year. She debuted at the very
end of Marvel's Age of Ultron storyline.
Wolverine basically effed up the space time
continuum and she just appeared not knowing
how she got into our universe and started
going nuts on the Guardians of the Galaxy
in their new ongoing book.
So Original Sin, or at least the Thor part
of it, is meant to fill in her backstory.
Her character used to be part of the Spawn
comics. Neil Gaiman created her and because
of a bunch of legal rights issues and a lawsuit
he just won. Gaiman brought the character
to Marvel and they turned her into an Asgardian
who's the daughter of Odin.
Spoilers for Original Sin, I'm going to explain
her backstory and why it caused Thor to lose
the Hammer. I'll wait just a sec.
Angela was supposedly killed during Asgard's
War with the Tenth Realm. They've only talked
about their being 9 realms in the movies,
so this 10th realm was a new thing. Because
of that crime, Odin severed the connection
between the 10th realm and the other 9 realms.
In the Original Sin comic, Thor and Loki travel
there to learn about what happened. That story
debuts in September, so we haven't read it
yet. So that's when we'll learn what Thor
does to lose the hammer.
It's possible he could reconnect the 10th
Realm to the other 9 or doing something else
really terrible.
So the new Thor Comic book will just be called
"Thor #1" debuting in October after that Original
Sin Thor Miniseries.
I think it's an interesting way to re-imagine
the character. They're not killing Thor as
we know him. They're just giving the Hammer
to someone else. There are a few logic issues
here. In their statement they were pretty
clear that this would not be a Lady Thor Comic
or Thorita or some variation on Thor. It would
be the main Thor Title. So technically Thor
would stop being Thor and someone else, a
female, would take up the mantle.
They weren't really clear as to whether she
would be calling herself Thor. Because Thor
isn't an alter ego. It's his name. Just like
Loki is Loki's name. It's not a secret identity.
I think Marvel will explain some of these
details at Comic Con. And what Thor will be
doing when he loses the hammer. Presumably
trying to make himself worthy again.
My overall reaction is curiosity. I'm always
open to new things in the literature. Because
they can exist independently of the movies
and video games it's a lot easier for them
to play around with the characters in crazy
ways. Which, if it ends up being a great story,
is a huge win.
Which character are they going to give the
hammer to? Who is it going to be?
The most likely candidate is Angela, the whole
impetus for Thor losing the Hammer revolves
around her. So it's a logical next step. But
Marvel released a couple of teaser images
and the female Thor did not have Angela's
ginger complexion.
That doesn't mean it's not Angela, but there
are a few alternatives.
We met Thor's three daughters when he traveled
to the future last year. Each of them embodied
aspects of his personality. It could be one
of them, or it could be Valkyrie. We haven't
seen her in a little while. There are a few
other female Asgardians like Freya herself,
she's been All Mother in Odin's absence in
the past and Lady Sif. I don't think it's
either of them.
I really do think it's going to be Angela
and they'll just explain the Ginger Hair change
somehow.
Marvel will probably keep the secret of who
it is until later this year, I don't think
they're going to flat out say who it is at
comic con. They'll just tease other details.
Will this affect the movie universe in any
way?
Not right now and not for the foreseeable
future. Chris Hemsworth is Thor until he serves
out his six picture contract. And he could
always renew after that's over. He's got two
more movies on that. Which will likely be
Thor 3 and Avengers 3.
So if he decides to not renew his contract,
we won't see a new Thor until Phase 4 or later.
Several years down the road. Marvel is really
good about hedging their non-Robert Downey
Jr bets. He's kind of an exception.
But if people get really excited about the
idea of a female A-List recasting, they can
always experiment with it in the movies. I
don't think they're going to do that, they're
not going to make the next Thor in the movies
a female. They'll just make a female character
movie like Black Widow or Captain Marvel.
That's what everyone is expecting to happen
at Comic Con, for them to announce a date
for the Doctor Strange movie and a Black Widow
movie.
If you're not familiar with Marvel's movie
phases, right now we're still in Phase 2.
The phases just comprise large story arcs
that cross over each of the individual character
movies, then culminate in the big Avengers
team up movies. Phase 2, Avengers 2, Phase
3 Avengers 3 and so on.
Right now Guardians and Avengers 2 are the
last two movies in this phase. After that
Ant Man will be the first Phase 3 movie.
Based on the amount of time they have between
Avengers movies, they can really only fit
about 6 movies in each phase. Unless they
decide to change that. They could announce
something like that at Comic Con. That they're
doing 7 movies in phase 3 instead of 6.
Here's what they already have planned. Captain
America 3, Thor 3, Avengers 3 and Guardians
of The Galaxy 2 and Doctor Strange.
That only leaves room for one more mystery
movie and if they turn up the dial on production,
a seventh. I don't think that's going to happen.
I think there will still only be six movies
I'm expecting Black Widow to be the first
Female driven movie and I think that will
be their biggest surprise during comic con.
If they spent so much time teasing a Female
Thor the week before comic con, it only stands
to reason it was to prepare the fandom for
an even bigger Female drive piece of news.
It's totally possible they could just announce
Doctor Strange and that's it. There's enough
time between now and when production would
have to start for them to wait till Comic
Con 2015 to announce a female character movie.
But it's going to happen eventually
The reason I think Black Widow would be the
first one to get a movie is because they've
already established the character and they
already have Scarlett Johansson under contract.
It would be a lot easier than establishing
a whole new character and having to cast them,
a la Captain Marvel. If you're wondering what
a Black Widow movie would look like, it would
be like a more Winter Soldiery version of
Captain America. Her just wiping more red
off her ledger, dealing with her troubled
past.
But now it's your turn, let me know what you
think about the idea of a female Thor and
do you think Marvel is going to announce a
Black Widow movie at Comic Con?
I'm going to be recording that panel. Be sure
to subscribe to get everything. I'm doing
a special comic con giveaway that I'll explain
in a separate video but Marvel also just screened
a whole bunch of footage in London. My next
video tonight will be a breakdown of what
that was. So you guys get double Marvel today.
Click here to watch it. I'll add the annotation
as soon as I post it. And click here for my
Ronan The Acusser Guardians of The Galaxy
video.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!